Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here again
to talk about language learning.
And I wanted to share a secret with you,
uh, something that I consider to be a very
important secret when it comes to language
learning and that is that it takes a
long time to become fluent in a language.
To even become comfortable in
a language takes a long time.
And I wanted to mention
this for a couple of reason.
First of all, because, uh, when I
discussed ChatGPT I pointed out that one
of the useful things that can be done
with ChatGPT when it comes to language
learning is to create customized learning
content so that you can ask ChatGPT to
create a story for you to simulate a
dialogue to, you know, explain aspects
of the grammar in the target language.
All of this is content, suitable
content, maybe comprehensible content.
However, I, I kind of wanted to add
that, you know, the question is,
how much time are you gonna spend
creating content with ChatGPT?
Um, there is a lot of content
available, particularly for beginners.
There is a lot of genuine,
authentic content, but there is
a lack of intermediate content.
It takes time to find
good intermediate content.
Maybe ChatGPT can be used as a way
to bridge that gap, but ultimately
you need to consume so much content.
You need to consume authentic,
interesting content.
You need to read so much, listen
to so much that I just didn't wanna
leave people with the impression that
ChatGPT was some kind of a shortcut to
learning the language we do and, and
ultimately you have to engage in the
sort of language learning activities
of listening, reading, writing, speak.
And so ChatGPT maybe has, you
know, uh, a function to play there.
And that's gonna vary from person
to person, but it's no magic bullet.
You often hear people say, you know,
fluent in three months, fluent in
five days, uh, master the language
in whatever, how many months.
Uh, you know, books that they
sell you, you're gonna be at, you
know, B2 on the European scale
when you complete this book.
All of that is not true.
Uh, you, you get a smattering, you
get an introduction to the language.
There is even one person, I think it
was Tim Ferris, who said, you know,
four hours to learn, although not
master, but to learn any language.
Well, yeah, you can learn a
few things about a language.
You can ask ChatGPT how the language is
structured and you can get an overview,
but eventually to learn that language,
to be comfortable, to understand,
to understand what you're listening
to, to be able to use the language.
You have to consume a lot of the
language, you have to acquire a
lot of words, you have to hear
these words in different contexts.
And you know, in that regard, and,
and this is the other reason why
I'm making this video, so I may
have mentioned that I'm going to
Sweden, uh, sort of end of May.
Therefore, I'm gonna spend three, four
days in Denmark, followed up by 10 days
in Poland in May, or sorry, in early June.
So in preparation for that,
I've been first doing Danish,
then I'm gonna do Polish.
So I've been uh, reading and
listening to this audiobook.
Very interesting audiobook
and ebook about the history of
Denmark learning a bunch of stuff.
I mean, every country writes
history from its point of view.
Denmark is the centre of the world
for history, insofar as Denmark is
concerned, just as Iran is the centre for
history, insofar as Iran is concerned,
or Great Britain is the centre or
North America or the United States
is the center of China is the centre.
Wherever people write history,
they put themselves in the centre.
And so it's very interesting to see world
history from different perspectives.
And that's what I'm enjoying in this
history of Denmark, which inevitably
involves other countries besides Denmark.
And because I speak Swedish, a lot of
the vocabulary in Danish is already
familiar or recognizable to me.
Uh, but I have difficulty
understanding Danish.
But nevertheless, of course, I
can go through this book, both the
audiobook and the ebook quite quickly.
And so if you look at my statistics
over the last two weeks, because it's
just in the last two weeks that I
started doing this, you'll see how
much I have read in Danish, which
I've done essentially all on LingQ.
I'm going from memory, but
I think it's over 25,000.
The number of LingQs I have created,
which I think is five or 6,000 LingQs.
So that's actually clicking on words that
I didn't know in order to make them known.
Or of course, if I turn the page, I get
credit for words that I didn't look up.
So it's not all words that I have
clicked, but it's words that I
have added to my known words total.
So that's a lot of words.
In two weeks, if I look at my experience
in say, Persian then you'll see that
since I began with Persian quite a while
ago, just how many words I have read
and how many LingQs I have created.
What's not in these statistics is how
many hours I have listened, because
at least in the case of Danish, I
downloaded the audiobook, put it into
iTunes, and I'm listening on iTunes.
So I have listened a lot, but
because I didn't import the audio
files into LingQ, I have no record
of how many hours I have listened.
But it's quite a lot.
Uh, if I look at some of the other
languages that I have on LingQ, even in a
language like Czech, I mean, I have lists.
I think I've read a
million and a half words.
Um, yeah.
And every time you're reading, of
course it's easier to understand
when you read because you look
things up, but I'm enjoying the
time that I'm spending reading.
I'm en I enjoyed reading
about Czech history.
I enjoy reading about Danish.
Uh, so it's not as if I'm in a
hurry to get out of this activity.
I am enjoying it.
I will enjoy doing the same with Polish
history, but I know from experience
that even when I finish this Danish
history book, I will still be a
long way from mastery or fluency.
Uh, I may have to read and
listen to a number of books.
I'll have to speak to people a lot.
Maybe I'll have the opportunity
to do that when I'm in Denmark.
Certainly, my comprehension has
improved, my vocabulary has increased.
I will be more comfortable.
I may not be able to speak Danish.
I'll probably reply more
in Swedish than in Danish.
But if I understand, I'm doing fine.
Similarly, in Poland, uh, if I understand
well, but I reply in half Ukrainian,
half Polish, it's not gonna matter.
Uh, I'm not there to prove anything.
It's similar to someone who, uh,
you know, speaks Spanish and learns
Italian and acquires vocabulary very
quickly and reads a lot in Italian.
Listens to Italian, but still,
when you go to Italy, you'll be
speaking more Spanish than Italian
and gradually you will shift over.
So just a secret here:
language learning takes time.
So it's important that you
find ways to enjoy the time you
spend learning the language.
That way, the process
itself becomes the reward.
Thank you for listening, and
I'll leave you a couple of
videos that cover a similar topic
that I've done over the years.